So, how is Apple making all of this money?
These figures are such extreme profits for a company...
...that only releases two phones at the same time, once a year.
The reason can mostly be summed up in two words: premium price.
Apple is focused on the high-end premium market,...
...selling their phones at a high price to gain a wider profit margin.
This, coupled with world-class branding, marketing and functional simplicity,...
...make for a deadly combination.
It can be said that a lot of what makes the iPhone so profitable for Apple...
...has more to do with the consumer's mind and what they perceive the iPhone as being,...
...rather than the physical product itself.
Apple's advertising and strong brand...
...also makes iPhones a cultural icon and a status symbol.
An iPhone is instantly recognizable and distinguished...
...from the slew of Windows phones and Android phones out there.